deux exclusions je viens se retrouvent
sur blood run qui est une sorte de super
meat boy qui se joue qu à la souris donc
faut encore plus de style
mais vous savez ce qu'on en pense du
style sur cette chaîne youtube donc ce
petit point rouge que voyaient tous nos
personnages c'est le curseur de la
souris je peux cliquer pour le faire
sauter et lui suit curseur voilà n'est
plus ni moins et j'ai dix secondes pour
finir le niveau donc là je suis des cdo
la mecque c'est tellement tu on atteint
le summum du de la dureté quoi pas tant
que m'ont dit si bien sûr mais en la
loge où à l'appel le curseur m'a souri
c'est un truc de fou mais ça vous il y a
vous savez la trad surchauffée [ __ ]
j'en peu près de safed secondes de vidéo
comment je fais là là comment je fais et
à chaque pièce que je ramasse et une
seconde vie en plus
aulas si quelqu'un est intéressé là on
saute sur le mur et des fois ici
ressources des frères autour pas [ __ ]
ok j'ai compris en fait il faut faire
tac
voilà parfait ok en fait il faut mettre
la souris sur le mur opposé à celui
hilde cela est totalement impossible
non là il ya des pics là ils n'ont pas
de ils n'ont pas de pitié ils n'ont pas
pitié fait remarquer petit temps de
pause voilà pour mourir encore mieux
mais va là-bas [ __ ] mais parfois j'ai
envie de m'absenter bordeaux a bien mais
non mais là c'est hors du commun le
niveau y est on est bloqués là mais là
j'étais quelqu'un pital level je vous
invite à tous essayé c'est entièrement
gratuit et heureusement parce que je
ferais pas pour acheter un truc comme ça
bordel de merde mais [ __ ] faut pas que
je me vois pas ce que de manger un petit
concert privé à la maison de retraite de
boules et les trous oui c'est une vraie
ville qui existent j'aime le parler pis
j'aime la piste des pins ils ont mis le
curseur rouge ces petites ont reculé si
fait que tu le confond absolument bien
au nom y avait des plus je le faisais
pas vu commence à s'habituer voilà ça
doit vraiment savoir en bas et coup
d'oeil si je vous le dis quand je vous
dit quelque chose alphonse vous me
répondez à la fin 1-1
j'ai compris j'ai compris là il ya des
pics là haut au nom oui
otis apparent au top et deux filles le
jour où les joueurs agent contiendront
autre chose que des pays où il est 9
rond ta gueule je passais ce niveau
coûte que coûte même si je dois vendre
mon enfant même si je dois voir ma maman
maman et et mon futur enfant
probablement toujours dans mes
testicules d'ailleurs sache que je
ferais jamais ça vraiment la difficulté
est tordu non mais essayer
et qui m'appelle [ __ ] oui à l'eau et
la lgv à quel travailleur et décroche là
qu il tout mignon au titre quand je dis
pas viril vous dites squeeze pas viril
pas viril
j'suis mort c'est intéressant de montrer
qu'à toi tu es vraiment j'adore ce jeu
mais je vais lui met un doigt dans le
cul en fait c'est juste une question
comme non parce que moi j'ai l'habitude
de jouer à des jeux style et aurillac
clavier là ça j'aime j'aime tes yeux
j'aime son odeur deuros c'est ce qui
laisse à en douceur non aujourd'hui on
va chanter les enfants way évacue le
stress par la chanson c'est ma passion
pourquoi je prends les pics l'a fait les
choeurs roquettes olalalala non mais
juste passer au moins un niveau c'est
trop demander vraiment juste pour éviter
l'humiliation voilà devant des gens
parce que je suis seule passion je
t'aurais dû être supprimés j'aurais fait
halte sub contrôler la fin du processus
bah tu sais quoi c'est quoi ça je parle
plutôt je suis pas arrivé au dessus
c'est normal de faire ça dit fois dessus
au [ __ ] de la sueur de squeeze et
c'est comme la cocaïne je suis quelqu'un
qui s'amuse beaucoup
je suis quelqu'un avec du courage ni ta
mère mais qu'est ce qu'on s'amuse sur
cette chaîne youtube on prend vraiment
amassé l'âge mais [ __ ] je propose
qu'on fasse un jt voilà touche pas mon
squeeze par exemple c'est très bien ça
comme une démission en plus je me suis
inspiré de rien ça qu'est bon oui
effectivement gilbert damidot valérie
qui t'aura ah oui là j'ai pris toutes
les pièces l'achat un max de seconde
voilà que je suis vraiment en train de
gaspiller de manière totalement
inconsciente dans la vie les gens disent
qu'il ne faut pas rage et et ils ont pu
teint de thor avec un marteau et des
éclairs j'ai compris la blague
excellence
le nouveau tube de ce quiz est
disponible sur spotted heures un mélange
de spotify deezer voilà la vie se résume
à ça bla bla bla bla tu vas pas le
bordel de merde qu'est ma belle
oui allô laurent ça va merci laurent et
aux belles écoles non cela ne me dit
mais c'est quoi ces scandales
aujourd'hui quoi tout le monde sait que
c'est en train de péter un câble sur un
sur un jeu et tout m'appelle comme pour
m'accorder quelques secondes de répit
aux plats aux plats s'emballer coup je
m'en bats les couilles je m'en bats les
couilles samatan part quand les gens
m'appellent et me disent que je suis et
viril à passer dans mes rêves et je leur
réponds que j'ai quatre points sur le
torse et ils me disent pourquoi pas sac
je sais plus et mon étal ces détails
dans le que j'avais fait à part les
sélections comme ça que vous prenez du
plaisir que vous êtes tous un petit peu
d'aidé jean sadique un peu comme game of
thrones à vous êtes des stars moi je
suis un âne histoire je suis tu je suis
thirion je dirais pas pourquoi peut-être
par manque de virilité ou deux
centimètres aussi au niveau de la taille
la taille corporelle ainsi je puis dire
alors le seul truc qui me console
dangereuse qu'on a ce bruit mais ça fait
pour ça ça maintenant celui-ci dont nous
tous ensemble c'est là où c'est chaud
voilà y'a pas bon nombre de morts chez
moi de soutien c'est magnifique
hop là hop la pop ont déjà attention
concentration non non mon gars attends
attends au niveau aaa mais chez madoff
les basterds qui campent les coudes et
sur toi d'en face ou comment ça se passe
twitter twitter de base et un rôle actif
à un pic ac salue ici lucas pagny je
représente florent pagny pour
l'eurovision mais vous n'aurez pas ma
liberté de rage et vont la voter pour
moi est ce que quelqu'un de bien map
éventuellement pour me sauver juste
jusque là je rage un peu trop mon dieu
mon dieu mon dieu mon dieu
bach bonjour je pratique le serre tête
de gamer oui si tu essaies pour
maintenir en place les cheveux gras et
moche ça par contre ça n'empêche pas
d'être nul dans un jeu vidéo
ah ça non oui bonjour je suis meilleur
quand je ne vois rien que quand je vois
quelque chose au revoir mon sort
pourquoi est ce qu'on les paie pourquoi
qu'on relève m merde je suis satisfait
aux ce que je veux mais je suis content
j'ai un message c'est comme s'ils
avaient trop laid comme s'ils avaient
t-bag un genre aux linguistes que city
bag est assez con et un cadet lui
consacrons pays qu'on se lève doucement
comme ça de succomber sont plus sur son
nez comme ça je reste beaucoup trop
d'eau mais là vraiment en fait me dire
que je mords toi sur 52 fois en 18
minutes et que j'ai pas réussi à passer
le premier niveau tu veux ça a eu un peu
le moral un bon jour
je m'appelle lucas hochart je suis un
jeu je suis un jeune youtuber de 19 ans
est ce que j'aime dans la vie c'est
jouer à des jeux rageant pour montrer
mon skill auquel on baise taha bonjour
je m'appelle jean reno j'ai joué aux
côtés de natalie portman et fait une
superbe carrière et je connais un petit
gars qui s'appelle lucas hochart et qui
est totalement une [ __ ] en plein new
york
on y va on y va je ne comprends pas d'où
je meurs dans ce qu'on va faire ok c'est
que je vais prendre ce casse
délicatement ok je le met là comme ça et
ensuite j'ai pas trouvé la fin de cette
blague attentes autant level select même
moi monsieur est beaucoup plus simple ça
se voie directe
voilà on passera ce niveau je vous le
dis de façon mad et généralement je suis
partant au niveau du jeu parce que c'est
trop ça voilà assez pas la fin jamais
les gens héros qu'il est au bout de sa
vie un peu plus et moi j'en viens pas de
cette vidéo sur jeu on s'en fout ça vous
a plus c'est qu'à nice dpm et la vidéo
comme d'habitude plus de joueurs agents
pendant deux semaines
voilà c'est la punition je me la pose ne
vous ai pas le choix vous avez peut-être
un peu le choix mais on fait ont déjà
reçu very low key c'est moi qui ai
dernier mot
on m'appelle oui allô
[Musique]